Traditionally in Renaissance Literature,
the muses,
and this will be familiar to many of you,
the muses are thought to
be the daughters of memory.
And the the nine muses up on Mt.
Helicon that's where the musicians
are believed to have lived,
are the offspring of the
goddess of memory. Um,
who's name in the Greek is [inaudible]
and [inaudible], whose name is, is, uh,
is spelled with some difficulty,
is spelled on the,
on the lower part of your handout.
Now there's an, there's an important,
there's an important
reason for this genealogy.
The idea that the muses or the
daughter of [inaudible] Mazda knee,
the goddess of memory in the,
in the renaissance,
the most important source of,
of poetic inspiration was often believed
to be the poets, the poet's own memory,
the degree to which the poet could
call up or just out of sheer recall,
literary toe point or
commonplaces literary commonplaces
stored in his or her a
memory from a lifetime, from a lifetime
of reading and, and Milton himself.
And this,
this seems to be true,
is said to have had one
of the most capacious,
one of the largest memories and English
letters he seems to have, or this is the,
the, the effect that we get, I think
for meeting reading, Milton, um,
is this notion that he seems
to have had one of the largest,
he's largest memories a imaginable
and that he's remembered just about
everything he's ever read.
Now we know that Milton was
blind by the time probably,
well before that time he
began writing paradise lost.
And therefore of course
he was an unable to read.
And even though there were
people, mostly young men, uh,
willing and able to read to him,
it's clear that the vast quantity
of learning that gets poured,
the all that air you addition that gets
poured into the pages of paradise lost.
It's clear that this is
not a product of Milton's.
Last minute review of the classics,
uh,
this learning springs from the
recesses of, of Milton's memory.
I take this to be an undeniable
fact. Uh, but this is easy for us.
It's easy for us to say. It's easy for
us to say that it's Milton's memory,
which is the fount of so much of
the poems Aryeh edition. It's easy.
It's easy for us to say that it was
Milton's memory that fast facilitated, uh,
his grasp of the Christian
and the classical traditions.
But,
but I,
but I think Milton would probably feel
a little uncomfortable with our easy
attribution of so much of the
poems learning to, to his memory.
And that's because to suggest,
just think of it to suggest that Milton
is relying on his memory as he composes.
So elusively and so dependently
in a lot of ways. So,
so much of paradise lost to say that
is simply to say that the poem has just
been generated by Milton and,
and not by God.
Milton has expended,
we know a considerable amount of energy
in establishing what he wants us to.
I'm assuming what he wants
us to believe is the,
is the divine authority behind the poem.
This poem,
Milton tells us again and again has
been authorized by that same holy spirit
who, who had inspired Moses to
write the book of Genesis and so to,
in order to make a claim for such a,
an extraordinary claim
for divine authorization.
Milton has to defend against this notion
that I just began this lecture with the
idea that memory is on some
level really at the source of,
of Milton's poetic inspiration because
to rely on memory as simply to admit in
in some sense is to admit that
this is just one more epic.
It's to admit that this is in fact a late
epic and that it derives from a close
studious student like imitation of
the great epics of homer and Virgil.
Now you'll remember from our discussion
of the opening of vocation to paradise
lost that insistent bid
that Milton was making,
uh, the, the bid to be first.
His adventure is song is one that with
no middle flight intends to soar above
the Yoni and mount while it pursues
things on attempted yet in prose or rhyme.
And so Milton and it was so with such
pride that he declared that this poem was
going to soar above all of its classical
predecessors. But the, but the,
but the category pros or rhyme is a,
it's a large one covers just about
everything I, I would have to say. And,
and the, the, the literary spectrum from
pros to rhyme of course would have to,
would have to include the Bible as well.
And there's even the suggestion here that
that Milton will be pursuing things on
attempted yet even in,
even in holy scripture.
And that is an extraordinary
claim for the poems, originality.
But it's a difficult claim
because even as Milton,
even as Milton makes this claim, he's,
he, he, he manages to undermine its force.
Um, and, and, and Mirror Hughes
a usefully notes this in a,
one of the notes at the bottom of the
page that Milton in that line, uh,
things and attempted yet in proser rhyme,
Milton is actually alluding
to the opening of another, uh,
another romance epic. This is
the Orlando Furioso by, by,
by the great 16th century Italian poet.
Ariosto.
What does that mean?
That Milton has borrowed this claim
for an absolute originality for he's,
he's taken it from somebody else.
And in doing so, I think he's,
he's doing this deliberately and he's
exposing some of the darker ironies
behind his own literary ambition.
Oh by, and, and it's, it's a,
it's good sort of questions that gets
raised in such a problematic illusion.
How do you set out to write an original
poem within such a conventional genre
like the epic? What
does it mean to, to, to,
to be inspired to write by the
Christian Holy Spirit when,
when you're at epic in fact just
imitates a whole array of classical pagan
conventions and how can you write an
original poem when you're literary
consciousness is essentially made up of
the memory of all the things that you've
read before. So this is what I'll be
proposing over the course of this lecture.
That memory is a problem that paradise
lost is continually confronting a,
so much of the pathos of Satan's fallen
condition involves his painful memory of
that blissful state in heaven from
which he had he had fallen. And,
and, and the problem of memory is just
as important to the psychological damage
dynamics of the, of the fall
of Adam and eve. But as,
as we will see when we look at book
four but surely it's the problem of the
poets memory,
uh,
that that's the most troubling in in
paradise lost Milton's own faculty of
memory. This is, this is the,
this is the idea that I'm
going to be a floating here.
Milton's own memory seems to provide
something like or pose a stumbling block,
an obstacle for his attempt to write
an original divinely inspired poem.
And so I want to suggest in this lecture
is something that will initially sound,
I assume like a peculiar formulation.
There's a strange way in which Milton
has to imagine himself losing his memory,
losing his memory if he's actually
going to open himself up to the muses
inspiration, the inspiration of
the Christian. They haven't news.
And there's a sense in which Milton we'll
have to forget everything he's learned
up up to this point. And there's
some important signs, I think,
especially in the first two books of
paradise lost of what we can think of as
Milton's.
It's a literary fantasy,
a literary fantasy of forgetfulness.
Okay.
So you as a, as, as, as, as you may
well have gleaned from your reading,
the first books of the poem are
particularly absorbed with the idea of
forgetting because more than
any other part of paradise lost,
they display.
So ostentatiously the remarkable scope
of Milton's Milton's own memory of these
books are, are without, without question,
more heavily as elusive that
than any other books in the epic.
They are steeped in the entire literary
tradition of the underworld journey
that,
that stretches from the Odyssey of homer
up through a Virgil's Aeneid and of
course up through all of the
renaissance romance epics.
And it's, it's, it's important to
remember that that Milton will,
this is probably an invariable
truth, but I will, um,
I'll qualify it nonetheless that
Milton volt imitate his predecessors,
uh, only with a difference.
He usually will.
He usually takes pains, for example, in,
in his great depiction of
hell in books one and two. Um,
he takes pains to avoid the standard
epic scenes of the torture of the dam,
for example, with which
we're familiar. Um,
if we've read homer or virtual or,
or of course, uh, Dante much later,
but there are,
there are nonetheless a few details from
the classical underworld that he seems
to have lifted more or less,
more or less wholesale.
And one of them,
look this,
I'm going to ask you to look
at page two 46 in the Hughes.
This is line five 82 of book to
one of these little details that
Milton has has lifted rather,
um, rather directly is the, is the,
is that of the river leafy,
the river of oblivion that was believed
to run a flow in the underworld.
And it's a river that I think that
all classical writers and a lot of
renaissance writers, uh, are very
comfortable placing in the underworld.
So this is book two line
five 82, uh, Milton far,
far off from these slow
and silence stream leafy,
the river of oblivion rolls her watery
labyrinth where of who drink forthwith.
His former state and being forgets,
forgets both joy and grief,
pleasure and pain.
So in this context,
the river of oblivion serves an
obvious purpose in, in, in this,
in the context we have here in book two
to drink from this river would allow the
fallen angels to forget their,
their fallen state,
to forget the fact of their
fallenness from there.
More blissful former condition.
And on some level it would
forgetfulness would just ease, uh,
the grievous newness of this miserable
new psychological dynamic, um,
with which they are tormented.
But there's also I think a deeper sense
in which Milton in which Milton himself
might want to drink from
this slow and silence stream.
If Milton could silence,
see what you think of this.
If melted can silence all
of his literary memories,
perhaps he could better guarantee
his fresh intake of inspiration from,
from the Christian heavenly muse.
A, it's a, it's a fantasy of course,
because no such Bryant brainwashing
is going to be possible. Um,
just as the fallen angels,
if you look at line six oh seven,
just as the fallen angels will be barred
from drinking, their fill of the river.
Leafy forgetfulness is impossible.
The fallen angels,
they wish and struggle as they pass to
reach the tempting stream with one small
drop to lose in sweet forgetfulness,
all pain and whoa all in one
moment and so near the brink.
But fate with stands and to oppose the
attempt Medusa with Gorgonian terror
guards,
the Ford and of itself,
the water flies all taste of living white
as once it fled the lip of Tantalus.
Yes, it's an amazing passage because in
a lot of ways I think Milton is actually
enacting,
directly enacting for us the reader,
the the impossibility of
such sweet forgetfulness.
As soon as he describes the impossibility
of forgetting a flood of classical
figures, pores, pores into his
own narration, and they, and they,
and they pour it with such a force.
I think that Milton permits,
I think this is a significant rift that
that fishers are fractures the otherwise
seamless text that, that we, that
we have in book two. There's,
I'm convinced that there's
something very strange going on.
Standing in the leafy of Milton's hell
is none other than the classical figure
that figure from classical mythology,
Medusa, uh, you, you know, Medusa,
she has the power with her snaky locks
to turn men into stone. And so she,
and so this seems to be unique.
Milton, Milton, I don't,
I don't know of any predecessor
that Milton had for this. Um,
Medusa having been placed
by Milton in the river,
leafy in the Christian underworld,
uh, can prevent, of course,
the fallen angels from drinking the
waters of oblivion, such as her power.
But we have every right
to ask what Medusa.
This is a figure from Greek mythology,
what Medusa is doing in a Christian,
in a Christian hell.
There are of course,
dozens of figures taken from the texts
of classic classical mythology who are
alluded to throughout the first two books.
But invariably they appear just as
Tantalus does in this very passage.
They appear within the
context of a simile.
They're not actually present in the
real world of, of Milton's hell.
Um, or if it's a, if it's a pagan God
who's mentioned, Milton will tell us that,
that,
that the Pagan God was just a later,
an earthly manifestation of one of
the fallen angels. But, but, but,
but at least within the context
of the present narration,
the figures mentioned in Milton's hell,
all are all former inhabitants of the
Christian heaven and the fallen angels
themselves. Satan lock,
Bilio, mammon and BLS above.
These are all demons who are drawn from
the Judeo Christian tradition of demon
Knology.
Uh,
they've clearly been hurled into
hell by a Judeo Christian deity.
So this little moment, that's a little
bit, this Medusa moment we can call it is,
it's,
it's really quite strange within the,
in the midst of all of the
Judeo Christian realism,
we have standing here, a decidedly
pagan, and I think this is, uh,
not uninteresting, a decidedly
female presence. And,
and you'll correct me
if I'm wrong, but I, I,
I think I'm right to insist that
this is a unique phenomenon in,
in these books. Uh, I,
and I think there's actually a
reason for this, for this aberration.
Medusa can turn men into stone.
She subjects to them,
to that posture of absolute paralysis
that we've seen represented in a number of
the early poems. Uh, the lady,
the lady in Milton's mask was,
was stuck to her seat in the presence
of the Shakespearian magician comas and
Milton himself had claimed in the poem
on Shakespeare that Shakespeare dust make
us marble with too much.
Conceiving.
Shakespeare can turn us
to marble because he can,
because he can fill our imaginations
and leave us and capable of thinking for
ourselves, um, and capable of,
of maneuvering around maneuver
moving around on our own.
And I think it's possible to see Medusa
here as an emblem or some sort of figure
for a similarly paralyzing power.
You could think of Medusa as
Milton's counter muse, if, if, if,
if Milton's true muse or so he or so he
hopes there. So he wants us to believe,
um, has a, has a Christian origin.
Then this counter music is
unquestionably classical. She,
she's a daughter of no Mazany the
goddess of memory and she represents,
she represents that force that prevents
Milton from forgetting all of the Pagan.
And all of the classical literature that
of course he had spent so much of his
life reading.
Now I asked you to read for today,
uh, and I'm hoping you remember
some of the reading. Uh,
the Canto from Spencer's fairy queen,
that features that came of mammon. Uh,
the Cape of Mammon is the,
is the home of, of Mammon,
the money God who stores in his cave,
all of the wealth and all of
the honor that human beings, uh,
spend so much energy striving for now
Spencer's hero in book two of the Fairy
Queen is Sir guy and Sir guy
and descends and demands cave a,
it says Spencerian underworld and a,
and it's in Mammon's cave that he
is tempted by the money God himself.
So this little bit of this,
a little bit of the fairy
queen is important for
Milton and all sorts of ways.
It's first of all,
a depiction of an underworld.
And so it provides Milton within important
Christian representation of a hell.
And so in that,
in that respect,
it has a kind of priority over the hills
or the underworlds of, of, of homer.
And Virgil,
it also provides Melton with the figure
of Mammon who will as you as you will
see over the course of this semester who
will become well here in paradise lost.
He's one of the the key fallen
angels in in Milton's hell.
Mammon actually seems to represent the
miltonic position or that position in the
debate in hell. That seems to
resemble most closely Milton zone,
Milton zone moral temperament we could
say and you'll see at the end of the
semester that's Cape of mammon.
Coke Canto is even more central to
Milton's sequel to Paradise lost,
Paradise regained,
which in many ways is a uh,
more or less close re rewriting
of Spenser's story with,
with Satan playing the role of Mammon and,
and Christ in the role of
[inaudible] the hero. Now you,
you also may remember
that we have already run,
we've already run into a Spencer's
mammon before this point,
before paradise lost,
a mammon had surfaced.
I'm testing your memories here.
Mammon had surfaced in the text of
[inaudible] and because this is one of the
most famous passages in the treatise,
and it's not one that we actually
looked at for mammon himself,
I'm going to ask you to turn
to turn to area up agenda.
This is page 728 in the Hughes,
the right hand column.
This is where Milton began to consider
the problem of temptation that of course
will become so important to paradise lost.
Here's a,
Milton is talking about the temptation
of reading classical literature. Um,
Rita and, and this is, this is an
argument that we've examined before.
Read everything you can.
Milton insists because only then can
you overcome that what he thinks of and
characterizes as the
temptation of reading.
So on the right hand column of Seven 28,
I cannot praise a fugitive and
cloistered virtue on exercised and,
and breathed that never Sally's
out and sees her adversary,
but slinks out of the race where that
immortal garland has to be run for not
without Dustin heat.
I'm going to skip a couple lines here,
which was the reason why our why
our sage and Siri is Spencer,
who my dare be known to think a better
teacher than Scotus or Aquinas go to
center and Aquinas or
medieval philosophers.
Spencer describing to true temperance
under the person of Gyan brings him in
with his poem or through the Cave of
mammon and the bower of earthly bliss that
he might see and know and yet abstain.
Spencer's Cave of Mammon is,
is central to Milton's to
Milton's understanding of
the Christians resistance of
temptation, the temptation posed
in aerial politica bye bye, bye.
Scandalous and seemingly non virtuous
books and Spencer Milton argues here,
knows the importance of reading
everything, the miltonic position,
however evil those books are
in and of themselves. Um,
we have to read them so that we
might see and know and yet abstain.
Now, this passage is famous
for for a lot of reasons,
not least of which is it's wonderful.
It's juicy evidence that it provides
for Milton's intense fondness for,
we might even think of it as a
passion for this earlier English poet,
but the passage is also famous because
in it Milton does something that he
almost never does. Uh,
Milton has made a mistake.
John Milton has made a mistake. He's
made a literary mistake. And as a,
as I think all editors note,
Spencer does not,
Edmund Spencer in the fairy queen does
not bring Sir guy in with his Palmer
through the cave of Mammon,
Gyan descends into the cave of Mammon
by himself that the Palmer has been
guidance guide up to this point.
His teacher and he and the Palmer
accompanies him on all of his adventures.
But this one and Spencer and
stands up to have this canto.
It makes it a big deal deal,
deal with the fact that that guy in is
descending into the cave of Mammon by
himself. He's been separated
from his guide. His teacher,
the Palmer milk.
Milton seems absolutely actually
to have forgotten something is,
uh, his memory has failed him. And, and
given the general importance that I'm, uh,
that I'm attributing to problems
of remembering and forgetting,
I think it's safe to assume that
something important is going on here.
The temptations that
mammon offers Gyan are,
are literally within the story itself,
temptations of wealth.
But they're also temptations, uh,
to the wealth of classical learning,
the wealth of the entire
classical heritage. Uh, you,
you'll remember that mammon has a special
place within his cave that's called
the garden of persona and
the gardener per syrup.
And it has within it all of the, the, the,
the central symbols of Pagan wisdom
and a beautiful epic literature.
Um, and, and you'll, you'll,
you'll perhaps you'll remember too
that Tantalus is present in the cave of
Mammon,
temptation,
literary temptation being as important
as all other temptations in this Canto
of,
of Spencer's,
that the temptations of
classical literature are so
genuinely tempting to Milton
that he finds it impossible to imagine
that guy and could have seen and known
and yet Epstein from them without
the aid of his teacher, the polymer.
And,
and,
and you'll note in this passage from
areopagite politica that Milton himself
calls Spencer a teacher.
Now he's a better teacher
than Scotus or Aquinas.
And the tech seems almost suggest that
Milton can't do without his own teacher
Edmund Spenser. Uh, Milton
Need Spencer, this is a,
an argument that's been amplified at some,
at some length and really
quite brilliantly by John
Guillory in the Book Poetic
Authority.
Milton Needs Spencer to
serve as the Christian poet
who can help Milton to fight
off the temptations of, of pagan
pagan poets like homer and Virgil,
or perhaps Spencer Spencer is a poet
who can help Milton fight off the
temptations of even as a
secular contemporary like,
like William Shakespeare,
the, the, the, it's,
it's almost as if the story of
Mammon's temptations of Gyan has,
uh, have, have hit a raw nerve in Milton.
Milton's lifelong
susceptibility to this story.
And that will without question
proved to be the case, speaks to a,
a truly profound ambivalence about the
pleasure to be derived from a reading of
secular literature.
Milton seems genuinely
ambivalent about the,
about all of the time and all of this
study that he has invested in his own
education to become an epic poet.
And I think that the metaphors
of investment here and, uh,
and of profit are especially applicable
since it's the figure of mammon.
It's the figure of Mammon who provides
Milton Milton with the literary version
of his economic account of Poetic
Investment and poetic profit.
So let's look at the first appearance
of Mammon in paradise lost.
This is page two 28 of the Hughes Book,
one line six 78.
Milton's describing the
landscape of hell and,
and hell here it turns out,
seems to resemble Milton's heaven
and that it contains deep within it.
And we would never have expected
this. It contains deep within it, uh,
uh,
soil that is hiding precious metals.
And so this is an underworld of course,
but there seems to be another
underworld resting just beneath it.
It's an underworld filled with gold that
a brigade of fallen angels begins to
extract with spades and pick axes.
Uh,
so this is what Milton
tells us at line six 78.
Mammon led them on this angelic brigade.
Mammon led them on Mammon, the least
directed spirit that fell from heaven.
And even in heaven, we're told mammon
was always looking down. It's a,
it's a kind of a cute scene.
Mammon was always looking down at
heavens golden pavement rather than
contemplating the more elevated figure,
uh, presumably of the heavenly father.
And inline six 84,
we were told this of Mammon
by him first men also.
And by his suggestion tot ransack
the center and with MBS hands,
rifled the bowels of their mother earth
for treasures better hid soon had his
crew opened into the hill,
a spacious wound and
digged out ribs of gold.
When we considered the degree of Milton's
anxieties about his own attachment to
classical learning,
I think we can see the significance of,
of mammon's actions here
that the image of men,
and it's a grotesque image of men rifling
the bowels of their mother earth for
treasures better hid it.
This is a group,
a disgusting and terrifying image of,
of a lot of things. But one of the things
I think that it's an image of is the,
is the practice of excavation to ransack
the intellectual treasures hidden away
in the landscape of, of literary
history is enact on some level of,
of a kind of violent desecration.
And Milton,
I think would need to defend
himself from the implications of,
of this act of violence. And so Milton
calls on none other than his teacher.
Spencer Milton seems to have dug around
rather carefully in his copy of the
fairy queen and he's,
and he's come up with this illusion.
And so you can you actually see this,
uh, near the top of your handout,
the illusion, uh, from the fairy queen.
It's the passage from Spencer's Cave of
Mammon Canto that describes this same
scene of violation,
the violation of mother earth.
The first discovery of gold for
Spencer took place when a Curson hand,
the quiet womb of his great
grandmother with steel to wound and,
and Spencer just like Milton after him,
seems to be associating the digging
of gold with the pursuit of a buried
literary past there.
They're on the same wavelength here.
Now,
it's not entirely clear that Milton's
Milton has been successful in sufficiently
vilifying mammon's project of
the excavation of Richards.
And I think in a lot of ways,
and this could probably be set of Spencer
as well and a lot of ways Milton as
attracted to the excavation project.
Look,
look again at the sentence that I just,
that I just read the last lines soon
had his crew opened into the hill a
spacious wound and digged out ribs
of gold that the fallen angels maybe,
okay, they may be violating mother
earth. Not so great, but, but look,
look what this violation produces out
of the wound are Doug ribs of gold.
The, the, the what? The image
that seems initially, uh,
negative begins to resemble, begins
to resemble something I think quite,
quite important and quite
beautiful. And, and I'm,
and I'm thinking here of the creation
of eve and Adam will tell us later,
this is in book eight, when Adam
recounts for us the creation of Eve,
that God opened up my left side and took
from vents or rib wide was the wound,
but the rib he formed and
fashioned with his hand.
And when we remember that God will,
will,
will dig a rib out of Adam's wound
in order to create the beautiful,
the Golden, the Golden Eve.
We realize how complicated,
how complex and how ambivalent Milton's
Milton's little images here in,
at the beginning of the poem,
Milton is loading every rift
of this passage with aura.
And there seems to be something, at least
provisionally, at least for a moment,
there seems to be something
potentially redemptive,
potentially generative about the, uh, the,
about the active activity of excavation
that Milton is describing otherwise.
So negatively here that he's
condemning here. Mammon.
Mammon uses this extracted gold to
create that magnificent structure,
pandemonium and, and, and the function of
this structure is implicit in its name.
Pandemonium comes from
Pan, diamond, pan, demon.
It's the place where all of the demons,
all of the fallen angels will congregate.
This is their political capital.
This is where they will,
they will debate their future
and established an established,
a new political institution.
This structure,
and this is something that's
important for Milton to convey to us.
This structure is genuinely beautiful
and it's not entirely clear that Milton
wants us to think of pandemonium
as unambiguously evil,
clearly. Um, it's, it's
evil in all sorts of ways.
This is the fallen institution
established by the fallen angels,
but it's more complicated than that.
Look at Milton's description of
the architect of pandemonium. Um,
this is the man who appears is the
fallen angels enter the building at line
seven 32. So the architect
of pandemonium is Mulsa bar
and his hand was known in heaven
by many a towered structured hi,
we're sceptred angels,
held their residents and sat as Princess
[inaudible] was famous in heaven for
building beautiful palaces there.
And Milton lets us know that there isn't
actually that much of a difference at
least in terms of architectural or
aesthetic quality between the palaces of
Heaven and the palaces of hell.
It's almost for a moment at least it's
almost as if there were a strange moral
equivalence between the palace is up
there in the palace is down here and a lot
of the rigid,
rigid moral distinctions that the poem
is actually been working rather hard to
establish are beginning to blur the line
between good and evil is beginning to
blur. Ah, look, look, look good.
Milton's account of what happened
to [inaudible] later on earth.
This is line seven 39
nor was his name unheard or unadorned
in ancient Greece and then I'll Sonian
land men called him bolsover
and how he fell from heaven.
The fabled thrown by angry jove sheer or
the crystal battlements from morning to
noon,
he fell from noon to do
we eve a summer's day
and with the setting sun dropped from the
zenith like a falling star on lem nos.
The Aegean aisle.
Yeah.
Milton tells us that the story of
[inaudible] in ancient Greece in,
uh, in, in Homer's account of the
Iliad, he tells us this story. Um,
and it's actually the Homeric version of
the story of most of her that you have
reproduced for you.
On the handout,
Milton is reminding us with this illusion
of the punishment of most supper and,
and the punishment,
uh,
and the punishment by implication
of all of the fallen angels by,
by an angry God.
But at the very moment that he's
telling us if multiple his punishment,
he's allowing himself to dilate,
to augment or to expand this beautiful
little nugget that's been excavated from
the pages of homer, and he allows
himself to linger over its beauty.
Just look at those lines again
from morning to noon.
He fell from noon to
do eve a summer's day.
If for a moment I proposed for a moment,
we almost forget what, what's actually
being described in the passage.
It's as if the, the story of
[inaudible] the punishment has,
has come to a standstill. And,
and, and it's, of course, it's a,
with no smell help from Milton's
incredibly elastic blank verse here of the
Headlong Rush of multiverse fall has,
has been drawn to a,
to a provisional stop and it's,
it's been drawn out in spatialized.
It's as if it's been spatialized into
a scene of a beautiful summer's day and
we're left contemplating
not the punishment of evil,
but I dunno, we're left.
One of the things were left contemplating
is the sheer beauty of Homeric poetry.
Milton has dug up a gem from
the pages of, uh, of the Elliot.
And this gym has something like a Medusa
effect on the poem or perhaps on us as,
as,
as readers time almost seems to stop
when we begin appreciating this image,
uh, solely on aesthetic
grounds. But Milton of course,
Melton's a Christian poem poet and he
will not allow time just to stop forever.
For,
as,
for as soon as he explains that most
of birth fell like a star on Lemnos the
Aegean aisle.
He adds this,
okay.
Thus they relate whoring for he with this
rebellious route fell long before this
is so mean.
Thus they relate earning four.
He with this rebellious route,
fell along before just just as we were
beginning to appreciate the loveliness of
the classical tradition.
Milton reminds us once again,
he reestablishes the moral polls of,
of good and evil.
Thus they relate burring who cares,
who cares about homer says,
what did homer or any of Homer's
contemporaries know about?
[inaudible] fell long before homer because
Melissa fell long before the creation
of the earth and it's Milton and it's no
other poet before Melton who's finally
able to sec to set the record straight.
So Milton's insisting here that
all of the Pagan Deities, um,
had originally been fallen angels.
He's providing us with something of a
prehistory of, of classical mythology,
a prehistory of classical mythology that
had of course been completely unknown
to homer and Virgil naturally,
uh,
because they didn't have the benefit of
the Christian story of the fall of the,
of the fall of the rebel angels.
Now without doubt,
this is a doobie theory of
classical anthropology and
Milton probably knows that,
but it's a,
it's a theory that serves an
obviously useful function for Milton.
It allows the poet to appropriate all of
the classical literature that he wants
to because he will be able, in the end,
he'll be able to correct that literature.
He can compare the myths of homer,
the earliest myths we have.
He can compare them directly to the time
scheme of Christian history and prove
beyond a shadow of a doubt
that his own version,
that Milton's own version
of the story comes first.
So Milton may be writing after homer,
but the story he's telling comes first.
And this is one of the primary
strategies that Milton develops,
especially in the first two
books of paradise lost as a,
as a kind of defense against his
dependence on classical literature.
Now,
Milton may not be able to forget homer,
but he is able to correct
homer or to preempt homer.
Uh, let's look at an at a
later manifestation of mammon.
This is in book to a line to 49.
This is page two 38 of the Hughes Book,
two line two 49.
This is a mammon speech during
the great consult in hell,
that the subject of the debate has
been the nature of the fallen angels
political future, where essentially the
question is, where do we go from here?
A molecule, remember, is the, is the,
is the military general general who will
risk absolutely anything for revenge?
Bilio is the,
is the lovely intellectual,
the intellectual seeking peace and who
prizes above all things is intellectual
freedom.
Our thoughts as Bilio puts it,
our thoughts that wander
through eternity and mammon.
Mammon is the profit tier.
Mammon is the Gold Smith's son who
wants to invest his talents within,
uh,
to invest his talents with labor and
with hard work in order to show a profit.
Mammon's advice is thus not
to seek revenge on heaven
or to give up as Bilio is
counseling to give up in despair,
despair,
but to cultivate all of the rich
resources that we have down here and hell.
Um, so line two 49 a book
to let us, this is ma'am,
and let us not then pursue by force.
Impossible.
By leave obtained.
Unacceptable though in heaven,
our state of splendid vassalage,
but rather seek our own
good from ourselves though
in this vaster assess free
and to none accountable,
preferring hard liberty before the easy
yoke of survival pump and a and a few
lines down and tells us that we will
work ease out of pain through labor and
endurance.
He's offering us essentially an economic
model that I think we as readers of
Milton recognize.
This is the,
the model of investment and profit that
had characterized Jesus's parable of the
talents. And it's the model of investment
in profit that characterized so many of
Milton's zone Milton zone, early
writings, including that promise.
You'll remember to his fellow Englishman
that he would one day produce a work of
literature that is that his countryman
would not willingly let die.
Now it's,
it's Bilio for my money.
It's Bilio who gives us the most beautiful
in the most seductive contribution to
the debate in hell.
But it has got to be mammon who most,
who most resembles Milton himself.
It's,
it's mammon that comes
closest to Milton's own, uh,
this pure [inaudible] of a diff
does diff discipline, liberty,
hard work, and this kind of absolute
self sufficiency in, in, in, in,
in so many ways.
It seems that Mammon is actually echoing
a lot of the political pros that Milton
had written a decade before.
It's almost as if in
the character of Mammon,
we have Milton's parody of himself and
that cry let us seek our own good from
ourselves. It's a, it's
a perfect miltonic tag.
Four for the first two books for the
first two books of paradise lost,
Milton is always seeking a good from
himself that is morally superior to the
good of his classical predecessors.
Milton refuses the state of splendid
vassalage to a kingly poet like homer,
and he's continually seeking a good firm
with his own religious and from within
his own literary literary sensibility.
Now,
when these two books
we've seen Milton dig up,
dig up and discard just about the entire,
uh,
the entire tradition of epic poetry.
And it's at the end of book two that
Milton seems to complete this process,
this process of,
uh,
trashing of his literary predecessors.
And so it's here at the end of the second
book that Milton is finally ready to
embrace the poetics of his better teacher,
Edmund Spenser.
And out of nowhere,
and I know that all first time readers
of paradise lost are surprised by this.
Out of nowhere,
we have Milton engaging the
fine art of Spencerian allegory.
So let me remind you what's happening.
St and flies out of hell.
He journeys heroically through chaos
in order to find that new planet that,
that he's heard about, that he
had heard about, and heaven.
And he stopped by a figure who holds the
keys to Hellgate and who can determine
who will, um, who was able to, to, to,
to leave and who was able to enter.
Now it, it goes without saying that Milton
has not been up to this point, writing,
uh,
writing an allegorical poem.
The creatures moving and speaking have
been actual creations of the deity and
with a strange exception
of, of, of Medusa. And,
and they have a substantial reality
within the fictional context.
The mimetic context of this, of
this epic, the, these are angels.
They are individual creatures who seem
really to be in hell just as they seem
really to have been in heaven,
but the figures of sin and death,
this is an entirely different, they
are entirely different animals, uh,
are mere personifications
of abstract ideas.
And it's not at all clear that sin enters
son death exist as individual entities
in the same way or on the same plane that
Satan does, for example, or Beelzebub.
And it's reasonable, I think to invoke
dot. Dr. Johnson here, Samuel Johnson,
who writes in his life of Milton
that Milton's, I love this.
Milton's unskillful allegory appears
to be one of the greatest faults of the
poem whenever Johnson as being
arrogant and and mean about paradise lost.
And variably he's onto something.
And he's telling us that
Milton has gone too far.
He's taken his allegory too far.
He permits a real character like Satan
to interact with the merely allegorical
or symbolic character like,
like sin and the effect for Johnson.
And who can say that
this is Johnson is wrong.
The effect involves an awkward collision
of different artistic modes and
entirely distinct planes of reality.
It's a,
I don't know if you've ever seen a movie.
Well there are lots of
movies that do this.
One of the first movies that did
this was the who killed Roger Rabbit.
If that's something you're familiar with
in which the interaction of real people
with what are called tunes
in that film is part of the,
as part of the film's pleasure that the
boundary between different levels of
reality, uh, is,
is crossed and Milton's doing performing
a similar boundary crossing aesthetic
gesture here.
Now it might be morally useful to talk
about the forces of sin and death as if
they were actual moral
agents. Uh, but, but it,
but it makes no sense within the mimetic
narrative that Milton has created for
us here in this realistic poem.
And I think that Milton is acutely self
conscious of the uncertain status that
these allegorical characters
that he has invented a have.
And so I'm going to propose this.
The idea that Milton's own allegory is
while it is a serious
allegory and it's uh,
and it's performing all sorts of work
that I don't have time to talk about it,
is at the same time a
critique of allegory,
a look at the description of sin.
This is a line six 48 on page two
47 of the Hughes before the gates.
They're sat on either side,
a formidable shape.
The ones seemed woman to the waist and
fair but ended foul and many escape the
fold voluminous and vast a
serpent armed with mortal sting.
Now those of you who've taken English one
25 or any course that has asked you to
read, Spencer will recognize almost
instantly I think, I hope, uh,
Milton's literary debt at the very
moment that Milton is beginning his own
attempt at allegory.
He alludes to the most famous allegorical
character by England's most famous
allegorical poet. This is
error, the filthy dragon us, um,
who charms us or doesn't charm us in
the first canto of the first book of the
Fairy Queen Like Milton sin,
Spencer's error is half woman,
half serpent.
And in a lot of ways she embodies
the very problem of religious error.
Dr. Johnson is his right to,
to suggest that Milton's use of Spin
Spencerian allegory only invites a,
a confusion of,
of what should,
what are essentially disparate
and irreconcilable categories.
But what Johnson doesn't
seem to understand is that
the confusion is precisely
Milton's point.
It doesn't make sense to speak of sin
and death as if they were living entities
capable of action and actual
influence, um, in the,
in the, as if they were
living entities. Um,
moving about as agents in the world.
But,
and why is that for Milton's from within
the perspective of Milton's freewill
theology,
sin can't exist as an external reality.
It can't exist as a force that can
seize the human individual from,
from the outside without that
individuals consent. Because we are all,
we all freely sin. No one can be compelled
to do anything within the miltonic.
A theology of freewill sin can only exist
as the product of individual choices
that freely willing people like Adam
and eve or like Satan before his fall,
uh,
make.
And for Milton to purse the world and to
rigidly determined categories like good
and evil or sin and virtue
is simply to be guilty of,
of intellectual error.
This isn't how the world works in,
this isn't the miltonic universe.
So Milton is alluding,
so unashamedly here to Spencer's error
because I think on some level he wants to
brand Spencerian allegory as
an erroneous literary practice.
Now we've, we've seen Milton
do this before. He's, he uses,
and I'm thinking of uses
in a pejorative way.
He uses a poet like homer to extract
what beauty he can from deep within the
Homeric mines.
And then he does that only to turn
on homer with that devastating.
Thus they were late earning.
He doesn't even get homer.
The credit of being singular
and having composed the Elliot,
they whose day he can't even
bring himself to say us,
he relates earning so powerful.
Is this defense against homer?
Homer was in error. Milton told
us, and Milton cold on the voice,
the moral voice of Spencer to help him
make that moral judgment against homer.
But one of Milton's projects in paradise
lost is to affect his forgetting of all
of his literary precursors.
And that means that he has
to expel from his system,
not just home or not just Virgil and
Dante, but also his better teacher,
Edmund Spenser.
And it's almost as if we can hear Milton
say after he's given us his own really
quite elaborate display of
allegorical poetry. Thus,
Spencer relates burring.
Now,
Milton may have forgotten in 1644 when
he wrote the area Politica Milton may
have forgotten that Spencer's guy in did
in fact descend into hell without the
help of his teacher,
the polymer for Milton.
Then at least at that point in his career,
his literary career,
such a trip without a guide,
may well have seemed unthinkable.
The temptations of the,
of the wealth of classical
literature represented by Mammon.
Perhaps we're too powerful,
uh, to, to resist alone.
But now,
now in the 1660s I think it's possible
to see a way in which Milton finally gets
the story right.
He realizes now that it is possible.
Perhaps it is possible for the Christian
poet to descend into the literary
underworld alone just as it was possible
for Sir Gyan in the actual fairy queen
to descend into the cave of mammon alone.
Milton surveys,
the wealth of literary tradition
before I'm any resists.
It's allure without the help of any,
without the help of any human guide,
he can reject the beauty of homer.
He can reject the beauty of Virgil,
but he can also reject and this has
got to be an even greater challenge.
Perhaps he can also reject the
help of his Christian teacher,
Edmund Spenser.
And so I'm going to leave you here at
the end of this lecture less with the
conclusion then with a paradox.
I think that Milton in paradise lost
finally remembers what actually happened,
what actually happened in
Spencer Spencer's cave of Mammon,
how the hero triumphed alone.
But Milton remembers this particular
Spencerian story only once he has
successfully forgotten Spencer only
once he has set aside fully his,
his teacher's style of
poetry. Okay, that's a,
that's it for today.
Next time,
reread for the third time.
You will be repaid by your
dedication. Uh, books one and two.
This time focusing on the similes.
And also,
as I mentioned at the beginning of class,
read the essays by Stanley
Fish and Jeffrey Hartman.